addition of two numbers is easy 2 plus 4
is 6 3 plus 9 is 12 and so on but how
are two matrices added before we move on
to how they're added we need to know one
simple rule two matrices can be added
only if they are of the same order yes
both matrices have to be of the same
order for the addition to be possible
now let me give you two matrices and you
have to tell me if they can be added or
not the first matrix is 1 minus 2 in a
row and the second one is 4 minus 7 in a
column can these two matrices be added
refer to this rule and answer this
question to know if they can be added we
need to look at the orders the first
matrix has one row and two columns its
order will be 1 by 2 and the second
Matrix has 2 rows and 1 column its order
will be 2 by 1 are the orders same no
they are not this tells us that these
two matrices cannot be added orders
different cannot be added here's another
example can these two matrices be added
find the order of each and see if
addition is possible the first matrix
has 2 rows and 2 columns its order will
be 2 by 2 and the second matrix as well
has 2 rows and 2 columns its order will
also be 2 by 2 as the orders of both the
matrices are the same they can be added
this should always be our first step
before we move on to addition we should
check if they can be added or not once
we know that they can't be added we can
perform the addition so how do we add
two matrices we simply add the
corresponding elements what do we mean
by corresponding elements the
corresponding elements
are the elements which have the same
positions in these two matrices one and
three are corresponding elements both
are the one Winnett elements for and to
our corresponding as both are 1/2 F
elements 2 and minus 1 are corresponding
and -6 and for our corresponding let's
see how the addition of corresponding
elements is done we will have 1 plus 3
here this is the 1 1 at element of the
final matrix we will get what will be
the 1 2 s element to get the element
here we add that one 2f elements of the
individual matrices that will be 4 plus
2 in this position we will add these two
elements to plus minus 1 and in this
position we will add these two elements
the two 2's elements minus 6 plus 4 we
have just added the corresponding
elements here and what will this be
equal to 1 plus 3 is 4 4 plus 2 is 6 to
plus minus 1 is 1 and minus 6 plus 4 is
minus 2 that completes the final matrix
this is the answer to add these two
matrices we added the corresponding
elements of the matrices also make sure
you observe the order of the final
matrix we got 2 by 2 it will always be
the same as the orders of the individual
matrices to summarize first check if the
matrices can be added using this rule if
yes then add the corresponding elements
of the individual matrices to get the
final matrix